again wrestlers are some of the hardest
some of the toughest people
in all sports but weight cutting often
breaks people so what's your thought on
weight cutting both nutrition wise
mental wise how do you
approach and think of it as a coach in
your own career too
it's a lot of discipline and it's a lot
of discipline during a very
uncomfortable time period that really
doesn't last that long when it feels
like it lasts long and it's painful and
but once you shrink your body down
and if you're hydrated you'll get
through it if you're a little hungry but
you're eating
but you're hydrated
once you break that sweat your energy
depletion goes away that's a fact i've
practiced that you come in and you're
yawning
and you're you know you're starting to
shrink your body down and it's that time
of year where hey i gotta get my body
shrunk down
and you're dehydrated you are dead in
the water but if you're hungry
and hydrated when you break that sweat
have people gotten better with that over
the years over the past few days i think
that coaches science is better i think
that coaches communicate it i think they
always have
i think the bottom line is is having the
energy to implement that and taking a
guy by the hand
when he doesn't understand and he's new
in your program and he's essential
and or he's unwilling to and not
discipline enough because when you think
them by the hand enough they will learn
that discipline
this is an important aspect of wrestling
buddy you know what i'm saying so you
know it's not just go and show up for
the match
i mean it's not about just making weight
either you got to be able to make weight
that's part of the
warm-up that's part of the process
getting ready to wrestle the lifestyle
yeah
you